extrait de son sixième album qui
s'appelle ennemis tout simplement voilà
alors toutes les chansons qui sont
contenus dans votre dernier album en
commun cet esprit positif cette
nécessité de positiver et de profiter du
moment présent c'est un peu comme dans
le film d'ailleurs l'auberge espagnole
finalement la morale qui sort du film
c'est profiter de l'instant présent
c'est un peu ça aussi vous oui tout à
fait dès ce moment les arts d'avril
savez ce moment aussi le moment présent
c'est tout ce que nous avons on n'a rien
d'autre
j'ai été élevé par un groupe de
personnes positif et c'est ce qu'on m'a
appris
regardez l'état du monde
actuellement on a besoin et la pisse de
la beauté intérieure parce que si on
dépend du monde extérieur pour la paix
et la sérénité
on va parler trouvait donc il s'agit de
ce qu'on a à l'intérieur ce qu'on
projette et je refuse donc d'être
négatif c'est vrai que vous avez été
élevé par des parents très affectueux
vous avez une enfance très cool linverse
de vous qui nous ont donné le sens des
valeurs
et pourtant départ ce n'est pas évident
parce que votre père s'appelle sai
kravitz c'est un juif d'origine russe
et votre mère et black des bahamas donc
c'est vrai qu'au départ le mélange
pouvait ne pas fonctionner l'ue était
producteur de télévision elle comédienne
et il s'entendait très bien y as lui oui
tout à fait et à ce moment là
c'était bruyant ses 24 ans 64 à new york
c'était une ville libérale aller c'était
difficile quand même pour d'être
ensemble mais ça a bien marché alors
votre mère vous a appris lenny kravitz à
être fiers de vos origines de vous deux
origines d'ailleurs mais elle vous a
aussi appris que la société vous verrez
toujours comme un noir je ne sais pas
comment c'est en france les états unis
vous avez une goutte de sang à l'art
vous êtes noir et peut être perçu comme
noir en le plus étonnant de l'histoire
c'est que votre mère était la vedette
d'une série télévisée qui s'appelait de
jefferson où elle était mariée à un
blanc cirque en fait elle était mariée à
un blanc dans la vie et aussi la
télévision et il c'est vrai que en
amérique à la télévision c'était le
premier couple interracial c'était assez
étonnant à l'époque c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'était une coïncidence assez
frappante qu'elles se trouvent dans
cette situation
dans la vie réelle et la vie la
comédienne à la télévision qu'il
reflétait la halle un autre cet étang 75
je pense auparavant il n'a jamais eu de
couple interracial à la télévision alors
très jeune vous passez votre vie dans
les studios de télévision pour suivre
votre père vous rencontrer des stars
vous rencontrez très jeune miles davis
duke ellington ella fitzgerald à 8 à
franklin james bond et jackson tom jones
vous êtes comme ça dans le milieu c'est
assez naturellement et à l'âge de 11 ans
vous découvrez l'europe donc l'aidesep
jimi hendrix les ou et ceci explique le
cocktail donc qu'est votre musique en
fête entre le rock and roll et la salle
est en fait vous avez été tellement
inspiré tellement influencée qu'on vous
a accusé certaines fois de faire des
chansons à la manière 2 non pas des
plagiats mais des chansons à la manière
de à la manière de la tamla motown à la
manière de led zeppelin et on vous a
même surnommé un moment rank xerox dans
ce que je faisais il y avait le goût de
ceux qui précédaient ma musique et les
gens disaient ah vous ne pouvez pas
faire cela
ça a été déjà fait
mais néanmois j'ai évité cette nouvelle
technologie algérie mon coeur mon esprit
dans ça et je pense que c'est original
vous avez aussi une réputation de
tombeur de séducteur après ben ouais
trompeur il a écouté
pas du tout excusez-moi j'ai déjà été
avec elle on se connaît depuis longtemps
c'est mon voisin de ma voisine
mais c'est vrai vous avez été avec de
très jolies filles lenny kravitz avec
liles a beau n'être qui était actrice du
cosby show alors c'était votre double
presque parfait lisa monette parce que
vous votre père est juif et votre mère
et blake et elle son père était noir et
sa mère juive donc c'est vrai qu'il ya
une espèce de comme ça de corrélation
entre vos deux origines vous avez dit
longtemps après votre séparation d'avec
reese a beau n'être que c'était la femme
de votre vie
est ce qu'aujourd'hui ça va mieux par
rapport à ça la relation que nous avons
maintenant et cela revient aux
merveilleuses parce que nous avons un
enfant
nous avons eu un enfant ensemble il a
fallu remettre en place notre relation
pour l'enfant et nous sommes des
meilleurs amis et ça c'est très bien
alors il ya beaucoup de rumeurs beaucoup
de ragots qui ont couru à la fin de
votre relation avec lisa monette
on a dit qu'elle vous avez quitté parce
que vous aviez une aventure avec madonna
c'est vrai non ça ce n'était pas vrai
bien sûr j'avais écrire une chanson or
madonna
il ya des nations mais vous savez on
travaille avec quelqu'un et la presse
doit qu'on est ensemble et la vente de
maradona alors après il ya eu vanessa
paradis que nous connaissons bien ici
pour qui vous avez écrit cette chanson
qu'on entend du tout à l'heure ça
demandait qui est excellente d'ailleurs
aventure aussi avec kylie minogue
c'est vrai tout pechoux les wav natalie
imbruglia vous connaissez natalie
imbruglia très joli 6 aussi vraiment pas
se méfier de lui elle a commencé comme
ça c'est comme ça dans la vie
ça arrive comme ça si vous suivez
pendant quelques âgées trouverait
quelque chose sinon est-ce que vous
plaisait tellement au filet ni kravitz
parce que vous avez tous ses pires singh
comme ça dans le nez dans les oreilles
est ce que c'est ça qui séduit les
filles je n'ai aucune idée et ryan
gosling jeune mais c'est parce que vous
êtes tout seul en face à widnes
égalisation
je suis ici moi j'y suis ici voilà vous
étiez avec régime non non non non régine
c'est trop impossible sérieusement si
vous avez un piercing sur le sexe c'est
sur le sexe oui and the bold ou non
youpi magnéto serge non sur publia bien
tous les cas lenny kravitz vous avez
vendu 25 millions d'albums dans le monde
ce qui est énorme dont 3 millions en
france et c'est vrai que les français
vous aime beaucoup et les français nous
ont accepté presque avant les etats-unis
gas ah oui oui oui ça c'est vrai les
gens avaient du mal à me catégoriser
tout est formaté on est dans la boîte et
en 2000 ans dont edouard agents du roi
avec les sols et ça c'est savais pas
quoi en faire
mais quand je suis venu ici les français
ont été très gentils avec moi dès le
premier album et moi je me sens chez moi
ici en france alors toute façon vous
sentez pas très américain il faut bien
le dire
vous avez été un des rares artistes
importants aux états unis à être contre
la guerre du golfe vous savez en faveur
de thé un tel endroit je suis pour tout
le monde pour que tout le monde soit
ensemble toute l'humanité c'est une
planète
c'est un peuple et je n'aime pas les
frontières
non pas du tout est-ce que dernièrement
vous avez été contre la guerre en
afghanistan
évidemment je n'ai pas de solution à
proposer ou à apporter à ses grands
problèmes
mais je suis en général contre la guerre
je pense que les êtres humains devraient
pouvoir régler leurs problèmes entre eux
sans la violence
on devrait pouvoir le faire et je suis
sûr qu'on peut en faire et c'est dommage
qu'on n'ait pas a pris jusque là à le
faire